tout d'abord
gagner à la blonde perdure cécile ma
fille
je six manches dernier à télé dimanche
nous avons retrouvé avec joie un
chanteur compositeur plein de
sensibilité de coeur et le lendemain
matin lundi au delà de l'écran nous
étions dans cette chambre d'enfant vous
devinez que nous sommes chez claude
nougaro dans la chambre de van zèle
cécile et bien oui avez fait vous vous
trouvez dans cette chambre
c'est une chambre où je suis venu
fréquemment depuis mon accident parce
que lorsqu il m'arrivait d'être un peu
découragé je venais ici avec en
compagnie tenir compagnie et cette
demoiselle
oui c'est vrai ça lui est bien
réconfortant pour vous l'accident
remonte à combien de temps j'ai eu mon
accident le 9 juin 1963 il ya un an et
la petite île il ya combien de temps la
petite à deux ans depuis la fin du mois
de mai c'est en somme si je comprends
bien que nous gardons dans votre vie il
ya eu trois étapes
il ya eu avant la naissance de cécile il
ya eu avant l'accident
oui il ya eu maintenant après l'accident
contre tout se termine bien
en somme vous avez souvent des objets de
méditation ah oui je réfléchis j'ai
surtout enfin évidemment vous savez
comme je n'ai pas mon imagination
je puise surtout enfin dans la trame de
ma vie les histoires de mes chansons oui
alors lorsque je dis que je pour après
une fille dans la rue c'est que ça met
plus ou moins arriver comme c'est arrivé
d'ailleurs à beaucoup de gens et
évidemment lorsque je parle de cécile il
s'agit réellement de cécile ma fille
enfin j'essaie d'être sincère je crois
que c'est mon c'est ma vocation la
sincérité c'est ça vous avez bien raison
c'est une belle vocation c'est à dire
que vous vous exprimez en chansons bien
des gens qui font les uns théâtre des
gens qui font des romans vous la façon
d'exprimer ce que vous sentez c'est la
chanson exactement oui ça coïncide pour
l'instant du moins à ce que j'ai envie
de dire et à la forme dans laquelle j'ai
envie de
parfaitement mais qu'est ce que vous
pensez alors j'y suis moi sur un autre
plan plus général de la chanson de
l'état de la chanson en france
actuellement je vois est bon alors
évidemment nous allons ici immédiatement
n'est ce pas m d'un côté en fait de
forme de charge un nombre tout à fait
qu'ils paraissent assez lointaine c'est
à dire enfin le léguer et puis de
l'autre côté la chanson traditionnelle
mais enfin actuellement il me semble que
évidemment la jeunesse en principe
essayé mais je crois pas qu'ils voient
là parce que je trouve c'est que
actuellement il semble que la vertu
primordial de la jeunesse c'est de dire
je suis jeune
or c'est une vertu je trouve bien
fugitive que de dire je suis jeune et il
ya évidemment également andy j'ai 16 ans
partout dans toutes les chansons
actuellement mais il ya de très bien de
très vieilles dames aussi qu'ils sont
payés
il ya deux jeunes filles de des jeunes
hommes qui ne qui ne le sont pas merci
enfin puis dans l'oeil également il ya
ceux qui sont sincères et puis ceux qui
trichent voiliers et puis on était prêts
à tricher
non je ne crois pas qu'il faille trichet
a noté regard et puis notre côté car
n'oublions pas il ya un roulement et la
chanson populaire depuis qu'ils ont faim
que l'arrêt chansons populaires par
exemple le style enrico macias qui me
remplit un peu de mélancolie parce que
j'ai l'impression et je sais
pertinemment que jamais je n'arriverai à
voir la popularité d'abricots macias
mais dieu vous avez d'autres récompenses
j'allais parfois oui en fait jamais
beaucoup de récompenses finalement
tenez par exemple j'aime l'histoire
l'école chauffeur de taxi qui faisait la
gueule parce que je lui demandais une
course trop trop courtes trop rapide
et puis qui à la fin lorsque il m'a
demandé quel métier je faisais je lui
dis que j'étais chanteur et que je
m'appelais claude nougaro qui m'a dit
venez venez ne ne partez pas je vais
vous offrir un verre
au bistrot d'en face il m'a invité à
dîner chez lui
en face et c'est le pouvoir
extraordinaire finalement d'une chanson
de se dire que monsieur qui me considère
a donné un méchant tout d'un coup grâce
à une petite chanson qu'on a écrites qui
vous ouvre son coeur à deux battants
c'est merveilleux de la chanson et je
crois que d'après votre action il me
semble que vous êtes tous que notre père
oui la patrie du bel canto
salut j'ai bien connu m père était un
artiste lyrique extraordinaire qu'est ce
qui fait maintenant
mais maintenant mon père ne chante plus
il est directeur des théâtres municipaux
de pezens ans et de rennes il est
directeur mais qu'est ce que le fait de
l'été gendarmerie nous a servi dans la
vie énormément énormément ça peut
sembler paradoxal parce que mon père
chante verdi et wagner et moi je chante
sur des musiques de michel legrand
hubert giraud et jacques data mais enfin
il m'enseignait une chose énorme qui
n'est pas tellement une façon technique
de bien placer sa voix et c'est de
chanter
il m'a enseigné à chanter en restant
branché sur son coeur sur le coeur
embêtant parce que si je comprends bien
vous êtes placé dans le domaine de la
chanson entre votre père chanteur éric
et même un service ihv qui est toujours
à vos côtés vous voyez je suis vierge
est très bien placé nous vous souhaitons
de tout coeur une grande réussite
si mauvaise